hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast optimizing g-protein
coupled receptor expression in mammalian
cells it is presented by Dean Scouse PhD
and Laura wingler PhD for both
postdoctoral researchers at Duke
University I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about our sponsor visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor in the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please use
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem please join
me in welcoming dr. Strauss and dr.
wingler we will I will now turn the
presentation over to them ok great thank
you so Lauren hi today we'll kind of
divide and conquer and tell you a little
bit about the work that we've done in
the lab that are that's trying to
express GPCRs or G couple protein
receptors in mammalian cells for a
large-scale biophysical and structural
work so a little background before we
get into the the nitty-gritty
so g-protein couple receptors also
referred to as seven transmembrane
receptors are characterized by seven
spanning helical regions and this is the
largest family of membrane proteins
there's approximately 800 majority of
those however are referred to as orphan
receptors we don't necessarily know what
ligands bind to those particular
receptors
so she couple protein receptors are very
important in converting extracellular
accuse or signals into specific cellular
responses and so therefore they regulate
a vast a variety of physiological
processes and so because of this they
are actually the target of a significant
number of drugs on the market in fact
about 33 percent of them on the market
target these particular proteins some
examples of that some that you might be
familiar with are things are known as
beta blockers these block the receptors
that bind adrenaline serotonin receptors
are often targeted and then several
neurological disorders and maybe most
also very familiar are the opioids so
these are receptors that are targeted in
pain
so a little bit more information on the
signaling that is downstream of these
particular particular proteins and again
the slice is complex but very important
biology and this is this is very much
true so these proteins are fairly
dynamic in nature so they reside in a
lots of different states and so in the
inactive state which was not bound to
its cognate ligand which binds to the
excess sealer portion receptor is an
inactive conformation when bound to a
ligand such as for the beta lift for an
a generic receptor would be adrenaline
for example upon binding to the ligand
the receptor becomes activated and binds
to a stiff a class of proteins called g
proteins hence why they're called G
g-protein coupled receptors once G
proteins are activated they do a variety
of things that activate signaling
downstream of the receptor and
ultimately regulate a variety of
different physiologically important
processes like any important signaling
cascade it has to be turned off and so
subsequent to g-protein activation the
receptor is phosphorylated and a second
protein called beta rest and shown in
orange bind to the receptor and turns
off the receptor by volt sterically
blocking the binding of g protein as
well as inducing a receptor
internalization in our lab and many
others have now shown that that the very
resin can signal in its own right and so
you as you can see the main point here
is that the G proteins can regulate a
lot of different processes again making
them an important drug target
you
so unlike most Seibel proteins the
structural work on GPCRs has lagged far
behind far behind those for a variety of
different reasons one of those reasons
is that they're very difficult to
express and very difficult to purify but
in 2007 Brian kobilka group at Stanford
crystallized the first GPC are referred
to as the beta-2 adrenergic receptor and
this is one that was bought in an
inactive State he subsequently
crystallized the same receptor bound to
its cognate g-protein and ultimately
this work in combination with Robert
Lefkowitz his work led the nobel prize
so again so the the structural work is
like far behind and it's important to
note that you know the structure biology
an important aspect because these again
are very important proteins in
regulating a variety of different
processes and so having a structural or
atomic view apology accepted function
could help us in to design better drugs
for the receptors and also just learn
how they work in more depth so following
those that critical work by Veronica
those this group there has been lots of
now different dozens of GPCRs that have
been crystallized using using similar
approaches that the beta-2 adrenergic
receptor but that said remember this is
a very very large family and so still
the number of GPCRs have been
crystallized relative to how many
numbers there are in the genome is still
is still relatively small
you
you
so how do we how do people typically
Express GPCR as well it's traditionally
people have used insect cells user or
called sf9 cells so there's a variety of
different reasons why you want to use
them so the expression and this is the
system that nearly all GPCRs have been
expressed into to date at least at least
they have been used for large-scale
structural and biophysical work the the
benefit of the system is that it's very
scalable and so you can grow in fairly
large volumes and again these GPCRs
don't express at tens and milligrams per
liter they usually Express you know
hundreds of micrograms to low milligram
quantities in a good situation
and so these cells allow you to scale
proportionally and because they grow in
suspension they don't need any specific
temperature or co2 requirements I just
grow a normal room temperature so the
cost of work both shakers is minimal
compared to other traditional systems
the infection methods were are usually
baculovirus based there's very little
transfer lipid based transaction
protocols or available so most majority
of people use baculovirus mediated
infections of these particular cells
so why not use insects as well
for anyone that's used in sex so the
variability can can be extreme this
every time viruses that are you used to
express these particular proteins can
vary as well as the the overall
variability is quite substantial I think
the biggest thing for our field is and
for lower and I is the the idea that the
protein functionality of gpcrs when
expressing to these cells is not is not
great in a one example that we have
listed here is again the beta-2
adrenergic receptor and so this
particular receptor we express usually
in SMS of nine cells and you purify if
you look at the expression of that
particular receptor it's the yields
about 25 mil 25 milligrams for example
from the states of six liters and when
you purify that and you actually measure
the functionality of that receptor after
purification it's a much much lower and
we measure that by looking at the
ability of its ligand to bind to the
receptor and so the functionality
decreases substantially and so you have
to use the secondary purification of
affinity chromatography steps to get the
pure and functional material and all
this is quite labor-intensive and again
you have to be you have to develop
different techniques for each and
individual each individual receptor
again in terms of functionality there is
there's just the functional versus
non-functional how do you separate those
two after purification this is an
example of only receptors that that we
we haven't worked on where if you just
look at the ability of the ligand a
ligand to bind to the receptor can vary
substantially between mammalian cells
and sf9 cells and so this is a simple
radio ready competition Radio binding
assay where we look at the competition
of a radio labeled I antagonist for the
receptor and basically as you see on the
on the x-axis to the ability of a cold
competitor and a guess to compete off
that hot ligand as you can see in when
the receptor is expressed in mammalian
cells the affinity of the ligand is is
quite good and when you express the same
receptor in sf9 cells this would be the
insect cells you see about a hundredfold
reduction in its ligand if any
suggesting that just the potentially
them the membrane environment can have
substantial influences on receptor
function
so another thing what more will talk
about more a little bit and I think that
some is very very important and nowadays
is that in mammalian cells you have what
we would call native post translational
modification so the consolation can be
very important for protein function
lipid ation fishing gpcrs is very
important phosphorylation all these
other different pesantren trans low post
translational modifications can be very
important to reset their function and so
again that these are kind of lost than
the insect cell culture system so I
think with that I will turn it over to
Laura who will tell you a little bit
more about the exact system that we've
now almost exclusively switched over to
for expressing and purifying GPCR thanks
Dean so the main alternative the 2n sex
cell expression for GPCRs has been
pursued is Animalia n-- cell expression
so there's a lot of obvious reasons that
mammalian cells would be preferred to
those from lower organisms the most
obvious of which is simply that these
cells are designed to Express GPCRs do
they have all the proper processing
machinery in contrast invertible
invertebrates only have a single gpcr
gene and mammalian cells rasinari told
you have hundreds though in many cases
the difference in expression systems has
a dramatic impact on the overall
functionality of protein so going back
to the example of the beta-2 adrenergic
receptors that dean already mentioned as
he said would be purified this receptor
from insect cells only about 1/4 of the
protein is properly folded and able to
bind ligands in contrast and we express
the same receptor one of the arms the
most common model systems of GPCRs when
we express in mammalian cells and purify
that the specific activity of the
protein is close to theoretical
basically all of its properly folded
enabled by and ligand there are also a
lot of other advantages to mammalian
expression that as dean was just saying
the the fact that the post translational
modifications are similar to that that
they would be down
on endogenously express proteins and
then there's also other on technical
aspects that are convenient such as the
fact that the you that there are a lot
of available methods for transient
transfection of cells and we'll discuss
that a little bit more in a little bit
so why have people shied away from these
to mammalian cells for GBP our
expression well there are a number of
technical problems of students delay so
we'd like to take you through a few of
these problems and what we found to be
some potential solutions to them so the
first problem is simply that high level
expression of GPCRs tends to be rather
toxic and this probably is not a huge
surprise because GPCRs are signaling
proteins and so when you would over
express them you're going to be
constantly activating all kinds of
pathways in the cells non-stop as a
result this is so can survive this
stress at all it's going to be doing
everything it can to down regulate the
receptor expression in addition of
course you can have activities at the
level of protein folding and processing
so what's the solution to this one
answer is to use an inducible expression
system so that you can turn the
expression up to high levels for a
relatively short time immediately before
the cell harvest
this was first applied to GPCRs quite a
few years ago now by the Khurana crew
and they demonstrated that mammalian
cells could be stable transfected with
both the tetracycline repressor and with
constitutively active mutants of
rhodopsin under the odd that were under
the control of a tete operator on this
stable cell line could achieve high
levels of redox and expression when
induced with tetracycline as this graph
from their paper shows in contrast when
they tried to isolate stable lines for
these mutants under the control of a
constitutive promoter they were
unsuccessful
repeatedly
another problem with the Malian
expression has been cost efficiency
generally the media is more expensive on
a per volume basis in the cell density
of the cultures even at saturation is
substantially lower than can be achieved
with insect cells however we found that
some of the recently developed line
billion lines that are able that are
selected specifically for the ability to
grow the very high densities we found
that the increase in expression as a
result of this has been able to offset
the these the increased cost per volume
and so on this slide we're showing data
that we obtained with the ex b-29 3f
system from thermo we transfected eight
different JP CRS along with the
tetracycline or repressor that I just
discussed and when we induce the
expression with doxycycline
all of them are expressing in the
milligram per liter range and as Dean
was saying before for GPCR this is um
this is quite high I'm quite sufficient
to be able to pursue biochemical or
structural work
you
let me also take out this take this
opportunity to point out some of the
advantages of using a transient
transfection expression platform rather
than the baculovirus systems that are
predominant and with insect cell
expression this is particularly advanced
advantageous for projects involving
mutational analysis of a protein or
where you might need to screen many
different constructs is often common in
crystallography projects well we have
found to be really lovely about
transient transfection is that we can
transfer of different constructs into
suspension cells in parallel on the very
small scale for example in just a 6-well
plate then the in this scale is quite
sufficient for us to be able to validate
the expression levels of our receptors
and to perform some very basic
functional tests like some of the ligand
binding assays that dean was showing you
then once we validated our constructs we
can use the exact same suspension cells
in the exact same transfection protocol
and simply scale up to on the order of a
liter to actually be able to purify the
receptor
as shown on this timeline what's really
wonderful about this is that we can go
from having the DNA for a new construct
to having validation of it in just a few
days and then we can go to a large-scale
run in just a few days more and that's
shown in the right-hand column
in contrast the turnaround time is
substantially longer for baculovirus
systems that are used for insects cells
and this is because you typically have
to do multiple rounds of amplification
to get the virus up to high enough
titers where you can get good expression
so instead of a few days it takes a few
weeks to get initial data on you
construct and there's a much greater
upfront investment of both time and
resources
you
this difference and the turnaround
really increases your ability to screen
constructs and high throughput so here
I'm showing data that we generated where
we had to screen about two different
dozen receptor constructs for a project
and if you have any experience dulles
baculovirus production you can imagine
how painful it would be and expensive to
test this many viruses so instead with
the transient economic scene X b-29 3f
system which we used for this it was
feasible to test all these constructs
and one shot in just a few days and the
narrow it down to the few best ones for
follow-up work
a final issue that has prevented people
from adopting mammalian expression
systems for GPCR biochemistry and
structural biology has been some of the
PT a-- on ppm post translational
modifications to come along with them in
general we consider this to be a plus
because these modifications are very
important for protein function and we
prefer for them to be as native like as
possible but there are some downsides
and one in particular has been
glycosylated so in mammalian cells
what cos elation tends to be more
complex and more difficult to remove
enzymatically than it is in insect cells
the the clinic oscillation pathway
consists of a number of steps it begins
with a common core that's added and then
it's elaborated by numerous enzymes
but the number of steps in the formation
of in link likens which is the
predominant the class is predominantly
found on GPCRs the end result is a very
heterogeneous mixture of glycans this
can be an issue for applications such as
crystallography where you want to
minimize the heterogeneity of your
protein samples so several approaches
have been developed to stop the addition
of glycans earlier in the pathway before
the species while still at the step of
having this this Viking core before the
species begin to diverge
so the first approach is by genetic
inhibition by knocking out a
glycosyltransferase
this again was first described for B
Dobson also by the Khurana crew several
years back and what they did was that
they created a stable HEK line with a GN
TI phenotype that is the n acetyl
glucosamine o transferase one which and
by knocking this out they block the
processing of in linked by cans as a
second step and as you can see in this
figure from their paper when they
expressed read opsin in the system its
migration on a gel changes from being a
very broad hydrogen heterogeneous band
gentleman lane to to a very despised
species which is in lane three
the same trick of using this G GMT I
knock out on a GK line has also worked
in our hands for other GPCRs that are
less tractable and more refractory to
expression than read option is so the
gels of this slide compare on the
purification from a typical native like
80 K suspension line to that of a GN ti-
line and you can see that the purified
protein and the far right column of each
gel that for the for the for the native
like one on the left the very faint
because it's a very very spread out band
where it's on the right one from the GN
ti- line there's a much more defined
species but what if you are restricted
to these of particular cell lines that
don't have the GMT I - phenotype well
there's another option to restrict sky
constellations early and early in the
processing pathway which is
pharmacological inhibition of the [ __ ]
oscillation pathway one example of this
is on kiffin dancing which is an
inhibitor of alpha Manas I taste one so
this is actually the step before the
before the GMT I that's on the spend
knock down these cell lines I've Tops
stopped all about again this is stopping
the glycan processing before it's
elaborated past this defined core so
this slide shows the results when we
purify gpcrs from x89 3f cells that are
either untreated or that are treated
with kipman singh so once again if you
look at the gels and in the untreated
cells on the most of the receptor is
actually part of a large smear which you
can see and um and the final step from
the SEC as in contrast when we treat
with given in scene we end up with the
receptor migrating as this double DES
this very defined double band
you can also see the difference on the
size of solution chromatographs of these
two receptors which I apologize they are
the labels are reversed on that the red
line actually represents the untreated
which you can see is a much broader peak
than the black band which is the given
inseam treatment so the where the peak
becomes much narrower and tighter due to
the homogeneity of the prep
you
another nice thing about about using
these restricted glycan glycosylation
either from GNT are - lines or from the
pharmacologically treated one is that
the glycans become much more sensitive
to D glucose d-glucose oases generally -
to fully remove the glycans from
receptors and somatically with with
enzymes such as a PNG ace or on endo h
they have to be denatured in contrast
often times with this restrictive like
oscillation the native proteins can be
can be pure skin BD glycosylated very
efficiently and they're still in their
native form by these enzymes so this um
this western blot shows that and in the
first ling what you see is is basically
the recept receptors that was not
treated with with the condensing or with
a the endo h enzyme and so is very broad
until you do i cosplayed with PNG a
switch has shown in that bottom panel so
then if it's denatured it will collapse
to a single band if you treat with Kip
adenosine there were some the top gel
shows that the receptor is initially a
much more defined band but even when we
dig like oscillate with endo age the the
non-condensing trait to the sample does
not collapse into the lower band whereas
the condensing treated material will
so another thing to note this is kind of
a word to the wise is that different
different decock oscillation methods can
actually have different impacts on the
functionality of g-protein coupled
receptors and so I mentioned that there
are a couple of different enzymes that
can be used to remove finish removing
glycans from from gpcrs with restricted
clock oscillation so png-8 p.m. GAF
actually removes all glycans species
cutting the bond between the asparagine
and the first light and the first
residue and this actually converts the
asparagine to an acidic aspartate
residue into h on the on the other hand
leaves the first on the first click neck
residue and removes the rest so what we
found with one of our receptors quite
surprisingly is that the ow if we
express if we grow this receptor in the
presence of Kiffin in seen to restrict
the glycosylation that gives us a much
more header a much more homogeneous band
as shown in the gel up top
in fact it has no impact on the ability
of our receptor to buy an ligand as
shown on the bottom graph and so you can
see that by the fact that the black
lines and the green lines are completely
on top of each other
likewise when we use endo h to remove
the glut to remove the remaining glycans
leaving only leaving only that last look
neck residue that also has no impact on
the ability of the receptor to bind to
the agonist in contrast when we use p
and g AF to remove to completely remove
all glycans from the protein that lowers
the affinity of agonist for the receptor
by about an order of magnitude
so the point being does really all these
modern
vacations are really important to
validate with your specific respect for
scepter in order to obtain the most
highly functional protein at the end so
in conclusion I hope that we've
convinced you that in many cases
mammalian cells are a very viable art
alternative for the large-scale
expression of gpcrs there are ways to
overcome most of the issues that have
really plagued the field to date
including on using circumventing the
problem of toxicity by using inducible
expression systems we can use on a lot
of transient transfection systems that
are now available enable us to really
start doing much more high-throughput
screening of constructs and was
previously feasible and finally some of
the issues such as um such as bike
oscillation and the issues it can it can
bring up for structural biology can be
avoided using either genetic
manipulation or pharmacological
inhibition so with that's the conclusion
of what we had to present and we're
happy to open this up for questions now
well thank you dr. Strauss and dr.
wingler for your informative
presentations yes we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar so if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is are there
strategies to help expression using
chaperones etc sure so um so basically
there are there there are strategies to
stabilize the receptor from both ends we
could say so one one thing that often
helps Express improves expression is to
express in the presence of an antagonist
so a ligand that will basically this
again is kind of gets back to the
toxicity issue so
lots of times even the basal expression
of a receptor can be causing problems
for the cell so in many cases putting an
antagonist on into the Culture Media to
basically shut down that signaling can
be can really increase the expression
levels
so that's stabilizing the protein sorter
from the outside you could say another
thing that has been done is on Co
transfecting receptors with some of
their transducer proteins like a
heterotrimeric g proteins so in some
cases people have actually been able to
purify entire complexes of GPCRs bound
to a transducer this was this was done
for a couple of cryo-em structures of
receptors with G proteins in recent days
so yes both of those have been explored
as possibilities great thank you are
there any mutagenesis strategies for
improving expression of GPCRs
so that has actually been explored by a
number of groups and there's actually
entire companies founded on that
principles so so usually usually the
strategy is just to is just to do random
eugenicist throughout the receptor and
then do high-throughput screening to
find to identify mutations that um that
improve expression so we always the
problem with me to Genesis is that it
always kind of leaves a question mark in
your mind you know why exactly did this
mutation increase the receptor
expression and lots of times is because
it's actually having an adverse impact
on the ability of your protein to to do
signal so basically it's less toxic
because it was there was less
constitutive activity and so when you
start doing structural work biochemical
characterization pharmacological
characterization you know there's always
some concerns associated with that that
you know that it's not really as
native-like as it could be
oh great thank you do other tags
besides flag give a reasonable level of
purification from these cells so we
almost exclusively use flag tag for
purification we have used like a 6x hiss
tag but an Rx and our and our experience
is those things that are like a nickel a
his tag it just tends to be a lot more
non pure at the end of purification so
we tend to use white eggs just because
the purity is that much better so we
haven't explored a whole lot of tags but
I would say a head-to-head comparison
between flag and his flag is far
superior
thank you okay your next one is in your
opinion why do you think heck sells the
gold standard for sells were not able to
express Milano Corten receptors or its
ligands but the c20 a four cell line
chondrocytes were able to express these
receptors Milano quartzion receptors are
gpcrs what do you think could have gone
wrong well so let me start off by saying
that we're yeah well we've had good more
consistent um
success with HEK cells and let's say in
sex cells with the GPCRs that we've
tried so far I certainly can't make any
guarantees that it's going to be a
universal a 100% universal solution so
it so regarding these specific cells I
don't have a lot of experience with the
other with the on with the other line
that was mentioned but it could be
something as simple as different uh each
cell line is going to have somewhat
different post translational
modifications a different complement of
of proteins such as that and so there
could be very very even within a
mammalian cell lines in general they're
probably going to be a lot of various
cell types specific differences
thank you okay next one is how about
Batman systems is it a nice balance
between these two systems to overcome
DNA Giga prep costs so um so so in many
cases a back man system is going to have
a lot of advantages where what's really
been nice for us in terms of the
transient as I mentioned before is
simply the fact that we can scream so
many different constructs and parallel
once you've made once you've narrowed it
down to a few a back man system can't
have a lot of advantages since you're
only dealing with one or two I will say
that that really with the working get
things in the leader scale you shouldn't
be having to do do Giga preps at the
time you know a lot lots of times
a simple maxi prep will see us through
all of our needs for a particular
construct for a run or two
and the next person says thank you so
much
after the purification with denaturing
conditions is it necessary to do other
procedures for the protein
um so first of all let me say that we do
not typically use denaturing conditions
when we purify we usually we want to
leave make sure that the proteins stay
natively folded and so and uh and we
didn't we didn't really get into it
today but purification of GPCRs on
usually is sort of an art field unto
itself what once you do gives up to
expert on high expression levels and
there's a lot of work that's been done
and regarding different different
detergents that can be used to help
preserve functionality and that kind of
thing so that's kind of a different
topic for a different day this next one
I'm going to I'm going to paraphrase
like you'd help me with it
um can you not perform lipid ation on
insect tails right so lip so insect
cells do so so for example a lot of GBC
RS have pol methylation sites and as in
insect cells and do Palma delighted but
usually in our experience the the
percentage of receptor they gets
correctly lipid Aizaz is lower than it
is in mammalian cells okay great and
excuse me if I mispronounce a word here
but do you recommend mammalian cells for
Bret B or et si
yes I
[Music]
I usually for for Breton you're not
dealing with needing large quantities it
would be a smaller scale 96 will play at
the end yes usually those assets are
typically performed and mammalian cells
because you because they're looking at
signaling and interactions between
proteins and so you basically want your
normal native complement of receptors
around
okay how about screaming and head cells
and scaling up in sf9 cells well in some
cases this this might be effective but
as as being kinda showed you earlier in
the presentation a lot of times we've
seen very different major differences in
the functionality of the protein going
from sf9 cells to insect cells such as
the ability of basically the affinity of
the receptor to bind a ligand so this
kind of points to the fact that the
probably the in many cases in sf9 cells
your receptor is simply not being being
properly expressed we've also seen very
construct specific effects going from
from one cell type to see another so a
construct that expresses great in sf9
cells doesn't express in HEK cells and
vice-versa a construct that expresses
great and in HEK cells doesn't do so
well in insect cells so it doesn't seem
to be a very good correspondence from
one cell type to the next in terms of
what does this
okay well thank you and if additional
questions come in we can jump over to
them but in the meantime if there are no
more questions I would like to once
again thank dr. Strauss and dr. wingler
for their presentations do you have any
final comments no I don't believe so
okay well I would also like
thanks mo Fisher Scientific for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May of
2019 please share with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
and also stay tuned for our next
presentation efficient purification of
recombinant strep tag fusion proteins
from XP supernatants using strep captain
XP it is presented by Dennis near Myer M
s a scientist at IBA Life Sciences you
won't want to miss it that is all for
now thank you three minutes hang on one
second
all right it looks like another question
has come in I just want to take
we one more question has come in but
it's a very complex question and we will
take that one after the presentations
very complex very technical and we'll
take that one after the presentation so
thank you again that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye